I guess I'll start talking well that
present
is being changed but it's it's such a
great pleasure to be here with all of
you friends mentors influences and I
love things that go on at Yale I was an
undergraduate here my my work is based
in natural history stuff and I paint I
grew up painting birds and fish my
father was born in Brazil he grew up in
a suburb of San Paulo and he fell in
love with birds as a child in Brazil
thank you yeah we apologize for the
brevity of the pieces but we asked some
of our favorite people and they said yes
but it's it's really wonderful to be
here anyway my father fell in love with
birds is a child in Brazil and when he
moved to this country at 14 he brought
that love of birds with him and to New
Rochelle New York and when I was a kid
growing up in southwestern Connecticut
where I still live in a town called
Easton I live a couple houses down from
the house where I grew up it's
relatively rural even though it's 50
miles or so from New York City my father
used to bring home volumes of audubon's
bird paintings of North America home
from the local library as well as a book
of paintings by Louis Agassiz suertes
who's still one of my favorite bird
painters and I'd sit at the kitchen
table and copy these paintings over and
over and then at about nine years old
some turbulent things were happening in
my family life and I my focus shifted
from birds to fish a rogue friend of
mine who is a troublemaker at school
introduced me to fishing and I fell in
love with I really fell in love with
fish and in particular type of fish
called the trout which many of you are
familiar with he brought me to a little
stream that goes into the northern end
of the eastern reservoir this our town
Easton is blessed with having parts or
whole of for drinking water reservoirs
so there's a lot of watershed land
around the
horse and there and I caught my first
native brook trout at about 10 years old
and I just thought it was the most
beautiful thing I'd ever seen in my life
and it had a red belly and red spots
with blue halos it looked like a
tropical fish and it lived in this
tannic dark water that you couldn't see
anything it was a totally mysterious
world and I became totally obsessed with
trout the brook trout our native trout
in Connecticut is actually a char which
is closely related to the arctic char
but I as well as Mark and Alexis are
interested interested in the history of
how we named in and classify the natural
world so you'll hear a little bit more
about that if I can get to it all but
from about nine years old to 28 I was a
trout were just about everything I
thought of maybe girls and other things
but and I started painting trout and I
went to the library when I was a kid
looking for a volume of other child of
North America equivalent to what Audubon
had done for birds and I couldn't find
one so I thought at 11 years old well
I'll make a book on the tribe of North
America so I started writing letters to
departments of wildlife around the
country asking if you know different
people that studied trout in some of the
mountain states and they sent me all
kinds of wonderful biological papers and
and things and photographs of the
different route and I started compiling
a list of all the trout and I based my
list of course at that age on on fish
that had been named by different people
and through that research getting
looking for old books in secondhand
bookshops like the American food and
game fishes by David Starr Jordan and
Walter everman I became interested in
the history of how people named things
and David Starr Jordan was the first
president of Stanford University and he
named a lot of the Western trout of
North America but I my list was was
based on what I could find and I didn't
question whether or not these were
real species or not whatever species was
I just painted them if someone had named
it but I soon learned that there was a
lot of argument among a theologists
about what trout worse receipt species
or subspecies or local varieties or
strains and I became very confused and I
had to make some decisions about what
fish to include in my book I wanted to
make so I did and and when i was a
freshman here i proposed a book on the
travel north american was lucky enough
to find a publisher i was planning on
becoming an architect and major in
english literature but the book i was
lucky enough to find a publisher and
because of that I just continued
painting and writing the same thing I've
been doing since I was five or six years
old so the the first book of trout was
about 70 fish of North American 70 types
of North American trout and then I
thought well do try to do a book on the
trout of Europe and Asia and North
Africa and trout are only native to the
northern hemisphere I think the
southernmost native trout isn't even
below the tropic of cancer and Taiwan
but as I traveled through in particular
Central Asia Turkey and Kyrgyzstan and
Kazakhstan I realized that nobody had
really studied the trout over there very
much and i am the in this but the second
book of trout i did which includes 100
paintings of trout from Europe and Asia
North Africa about more than a third of
it is just diversity within a single
species of trout the brown trout called
salmo trutta the Linnaean binomial but
in the process of making that book I
thought what an injustice it is that all
this diversity is crammed with in one
species named the brown trout salmo
trutta and I I just started to kind of
bother me in my travels mostly with this
amateur biologists from Austria Johanna
Schiffman who's a baker by profession
very strange guy but wonderful man who
publishes scientific papers and a
Austrian fisheries journal we travel for
eight years together too many
interesting places some of them
politically turbulent southeast Turkey
we were looking for trout in the
headwaters of the Tigris River which we
didn't get because the Turkish army was
fighting the Kurdish guerrillas and
wouldn't let us into the headwaters we
wanted to go but he went back a couple
years later and did catch and
photographed the first trout from the
headwaters of the Tigris I can go off on
different tangents but i'll try to stay
focused the Tigers fish is particularly
interesting because it's a at the
headwaters of the the Tigris which flows
to the Indian Ocean there were never
trout in the Indian Ocean so they
crossed from headwaters of other other
places like the Caspian and the Black
Sea and the Mediterranean so they're
actually kind of a hybrid of the anyway
I didn't mean to get into a trout
dissertation just don't ask me about
eels I'll never stop talking but these
are just a sort of a smattering of some
of the fish that I painted for that book
which came out in 2003 these are
actually all types of brown trout I
hesitate to use the word subspecies
because I have issues with all those
monikers and with the Linnaean system
which as Mark said people have offered
alternatives to like the philo code
which Michael Donahue and Jacques Gotye
here at Yale have pioneered with Kevin
de Quiros at the Smithsonian which would
pretty much eliminate all the higher
ranks of the Linnaean system the family
phylum I don't even know them but they
don't really matter that much in my mind
because they're not real entities
they're just they're just categories we
fit nature and because our mind likes to
put things in hierarchies it but it
works it's worked so well for so long
because it conforms to the way the human
mind works but is there a better system
i'm not sure i'm i'm writing an article
for National Geographic right now about
the future of taxonomy so I'll be
inquiring about this stuff but an
alternative may not be in sight that the
internet does allow us to have sort of
more web like interaction and may be
able to handle some of the complexities
of biological reality that
were coming to know faster and faster
now in the last decade I any one of
these points I could continue going on
but I have like 70 images this is adam
and eve adam of course as a story goes
is the first name ur God gives him the
the privilege or the he it's his first
task in the garden is to name everything
and depending on whatever translation
you whatever we want to translate it
it's sort of a way of taking control of
the animals in the garden there's a
great story by ursula leguin called she
uh names them where eve goes through the
garden unnamed um named and when she's
finished she hands her name back to Adam
and says see you later so it was sort of
a set a feminist thing in the eye thing
was in the 80s it was like a one page
story in The New Yorker it's really
beautiful but I can hand out copies
later as Mark and Alexis are I'm
interested in the history of exploration
and Bob and aiming everybody here
Christoph I am interested in this time
when we started going abroad and
merchant companies started building
ships that were capable of going too far
off places collecting spices and riches
and they came back with all this stuff
from overseas and that's really what
made Linnaeus necessary because you know
your Northern Europeans only needed to
know 200 is so different animals before
all this all this stuff started coming
in from the tropics and overwhelming
northern Europe and somebody had to step
up and create a system to name it all
and classified also we could you know
communicate about nature and as as much
as I don't like the idea of species or
the name species because i think it
caused a lot of trouble with
policymaking and stuff like the
Endangered Species Act does that mean
you can't you can't protect something
that's not a species and and what if
nobody can define what a species is
because nobody can and it's different
from fish to birds to coral to plants
it's become a real a real problem
it was something else I was going to say
but I'll keep going just this is the
reach of the feo stay the Dutch East
Indies company they just went everywhere
they brought all this stuff back and
these great pictures were being made
this is a famous picture of a rhinoceros
by der who drew it from just rumors of a
rhinoceros that some kind of ship I
think on its way to Lisbon but I I'm
trying to go back to a time before these
standard systems existed because I think
along with these standard systems come
an assumption that they're actually real
but there I don't think they they're
based on reality and the linnean system
has been flexible enough to accommodate
the things we've learned through
molecular research and genetic stuff but
a cabinet of curiosity there I have been
talking 10 minutes is a or less just a
beautiful picture of a seaweed from an
exhibition at the Yale Center for
British are a couple years ago called
ocean flowers which were commissioned by
British people in India I think I may be
mistaken but were made by South people
who were trained in the Southeast Asian
miniature tradition and geometry is a
big part of those pictures they make so
they compose the seaweed in incredible
ways when you hold see boots just like
wet hair there's no way to really draw
it but and when these pictures came back
to England they influence the history of
natural history painting from then on
bird of paradise this is maria sibylla
Merriam's painting of a white witch moth
the caterpillars incorrect Christophe
and I one of our dreams is to find the
caterpillar of the white witch moth
because it's unknown but it's been
assumed that it's known because of this
painting until a couple years ago when
we realize nobody really knows what it
is this is unclad it's not the same
picture of linnaeus mark had but that's
that I think the title page of the first
edition so around 20 years old I I
painted as many trout as I could sort of
stand i guess and i thought well now i
want to comment on our relationship to
nature a little bit more and and through
the avenue of
temporary which is a very peculiar world
I think but but a world where you can
navigate with ideas and really have fun
thinking and not necessarily have to be
associated with the university but I
started making these hybrid pictures of
creatures that became their names and
protests of being named like a parrot
fish and a turtle dove and a Kingfisher
and and I put little things next to them
that are sort of like you know a duck
trout I don't think there's such a thing
but some people say wow is there really
a see Pegasus or flying fox with the
collectors tulle at the bottom this is
then I did some tool birds this is a
cockatoo lit has a crest of a Swiss Army
knife because humans the commentary
about conservation we tend to conserve
things that are useful to us so these
creatures of all time' cumin industry in
order to survive this is a drill duck
this is a sailfish and then i started
doing these things traditional natural
history painting you have the common and
scientific name of the creature
underneath it so i took the names away
and replace them with these curvilinear
lines which to me express the the place
of the creature in the ecosystem without
having to name it the sea dragon that's
a foretaste painting that i copied and
put some lines around it pheasants and
then i did this mural at the aldrich
contemporary art museum which is a i
blew up the endpapers of raja tori
Peterson's field guide to birds where
there's silhouettes and numbers and
you're supposed to match the numbers up
with the names to identify them so i
left the numbers and took out the names
and nobody could could identify them
this is our beloved Peabody where I've
been going since I was five years old
and now I've been lucky enough to help
out with things the dioramas of course
and I and as part of this naming inquiry
I wanted to go on a collecting trip with
a museum as soon as I found out they
were still doing it which I couldn't
really believe they still went in the
jungle and with nets and guns and it
seemed that would have been my perfect
job description if I'd lived in the 19th
century but I now I
cuz that job description doesn't really
exist I have to kind of comment on it so
I went Christoph organized it expedition
to surinam here I didn't even know we're
sure name was before I went on this trip
but we saw some cool stuff and moths
there's a white witch that Maria sibling
Miriam painted snakes it's going into
the pot I don't know if we ate it but
beautiful stuff that i painted
Christophe found a new species of bird
which he's still in the process of
naming so I was able to seed naming
firsthand this is christoph and burnt
heinrich a great writer who was on the
trip and just killing and painting
things but i loved it it was amazing I
I'll wrap up in the next 30 seconds I
hope or this is a like Alexis and Mark
also like to go into the field as part
of my research for my writing and my
painting and I have a book coming out
about paintings of ocean fish but I
wanted to paint them all life-size from
individual fish not a species not not a
painting to represent a species in a
field guide but in an intimate
relationship I had with a particular
fish so I went on this harpoon boat in
Nova Scotia off Nova Scotian Georges
Bank there's a swordfish dorsal fin over
his left shoulder the harpooner he stuck
the harpoon in there's the swordfish the
harpoon head went right through and
there's the swordfish anyway I painted
them life-size so I could show some of
the abstract beauty of the of the
different fish these are just some of
them I think mark caught that one and
grouper I mean I think a group is an
amazing looking fish and then I get to
put silhouettes and the end papers which
is theirs and then I just the last
couple I've been doing taxidermied
versions of some of the tool creatures
and hybrids because in the Natural
History Museum the dead thing is the
proof of its existence so some people
actually think there's a drill duck now
in
of sleeping flying fox and these are the
most recent things I've been making
taking an existing bone like a cow
vertebra and building an extension of it
that that shows where it might have gone
if it had given the opportunity there's
an antler where I connected the times
and these are some of those anyway
that's my talk thank you very much